-My first guest stars
and produces one of
the biggest franchises
in movie history.
The latest installment, "F9,"
hits theaters this Friday.
Here is Vin Diesel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Mister Vin Diesel ♪
♪ Spendin' time with us ♪
♪ His latest movie is ♪
♪ "Fast and Furious" ♪
♪ Mister Vin Diesel ♪
♪ Finally it's time ♪
♪ Want some excitement? ♪
♪ Snap into "F9" ♪
♪ Yeah-ah-ah-ah ♪
-That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I'm talking about.
Hey!
Hey! You feel that?
You feel that love right there,
Vin Diesel?
-What's up, boys?
-You feel the love. Come on.
-I'm -- Yo. Jimmy.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at these people.
Look at these --
-Yeah, Please. Please.
Welcome --
-No, no, Jimmy.
Look at these people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know! I do! I know! Yeah.
I know! I know!
They're unbelievable!
-We got humans!
-Well, we have humans
in the building.
Thank you so much.
-Humans in the building.
There's humans!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Please.
I know it's a big deal for you
to come in person on the show.
It means a lot to us.
But I know you and New York --
I mean, you know, you love
New Yorkers, and you love --
Yeah, so you had to come back.
-Had to come back.
Love New Yorkers.
Love you.
Love what you do here.
-Thank you, bud,
I appreciate it, man.
It means a lot to us.
-Do you guys see
how happy he is?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I am.
I can't -- I can't stop --
Well, every time --
No, no, no.
I can't wait for this
because every time
you've been on
throughout the years,
you've supported us, thanks.
But we always get into
some cool thing
that I didn't know about you.
You're a very mysterious guy.
You have a lot of mystique
around you.
-Fair.
-And one time, I found out
that you were a rapper.
I found out you were
a break dancer.
You actually showed us
some moves on the show.
-That's right.
-And I remember that.
That was great.
But I did not know that you did
an instructional video...
-Uh-oh.
-...on how to breakdance.
-Do you remember --
Do you remember doing this?
-Oh, my God.
Yes, I do remember doing this.
It was the highlight of my life.
-I will refresh your memory.
Here's Vin Diesel.
I don't know when.
Teaching you how to breakdance.
Take a look at this.
-...the right
and cross the left.
Remove the left leg
and replace further left.
♪♪
-That's my move!
That's my move at the club!
I go to the club.
That's my move I always do.
I go, "Oh, my God.
Just stand still.
I'm just gonna worm
through you and out."
-Wow.
-Oh, my gosh.
That was -- That was it.
That was the big time.
-The side -- The side worm.
It was the side worm.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Side worm.
-I've never seen
a side worm, to be honest.
-Yeah, it was a side worm.
It was a big hit
at Columbus Circle.
-20 years ago today is when
"Fast and the Furious" started.
-[ Imitates explosion ]
-This franchise --
Did you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's bigger than big.
It's unstoppable.
-It's so big!
-It's Vin Diesel big.
-Guys!
-It's so big!
It's Vin Diesel big!
That's how big it is.
How big is it?
It is Vin Diesel big!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Guys.
20 years ago today
was the release of the first
"Fast and the Furious" movie.
-Wow.
-And you were all a part of it.
Those of you that were born.
[ Laughter ]
Do you remember where you were?
-20 years ago?
-At the "Fast and the Furious"
premiere?
You're like,
"I wasn't at the premiere."
-Yeah, yeah, probably was.
-Jimmy, you were there.
-Of course I was there.
-You were always there.
-I was, like, "Dude,
let's take this Ford Fiesta."
-Yes!
-I'm grabbing a Ford Fiesta,
and you're like, "Yeah,
I'm going to take the movie
in a different direction."
Yeah, I go --
I was more furious than fast.
-And you gotta forgive
Jimmy and myself. It's so --
such a great feeling
to see a roomful --
-A crowd.
-A crowd. An audience.
-Feels good, right?
-It's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It feels good. It's amazing.
-So it's not like
a normal show.
So that's how come
I keep wanting to get up
and I want them lights
to be on you.
And I want to see you,
and I want to...
rejoice with you.
-Yes!
-And I want to bring back
New York with you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're coming back.
I love that.
-New York.
We're coming back!